what was the impetus for you to
investigate something so potentially
Fantastical as a wormhole
um
well the
this came out of thinking about black
holes and the black hole interior and
entanglement
so there is a
of course wormholes are fascinating to
think about regardless and that's also
why we're thinking about this
but one post seemed like they are very
exotic however something like a wormhole
is already present in the simplest
solution of general relativity so if you
take the general activity with the
vacuum solution and it's spherically
symmetrics we assume is spherical
symmetry there is some solution which
schwarzheil wrote which sometimes we
call it the black hole solution or the
short shot solution
and that solution has the peculiarity
that it has two exteriors connected by a
single interior
um
and this was a funny feature that the
Einstein and Rosen noticed in the 30s
and um and yeah it's been well known for
a long time and
so this solution has the geometry of a
wormhole at the spatial instant so at an
instant of time in time you have a
three-dimensional space our three let's
say imagine you we had the solution we
would have our three-dimensional space
is connected through a wormhole to a
second copy of another three-dimensional
space
um
it has the funny feature that the
Wormhole is not traversable so if you
try to go from one side to the other you
find that the solution is time dependent
and this geometric connection closes off
and
there is a part of space that shrinks
you have a kind of big crunch in the
in this Wormhole it shrinks it's very
similar to what would happen if you took
a piece of dough and you stretched it a
lot it becomes very thin and that's what
happens to this geometry
and the resulting very thin space is
what we normally call the black hole
Singularity so if you try to Traverse it
you just end the singularity you die so
that's fine that's not avoided yes
yeah
so that that's uh that's present already
in that solution it's uh not traversable
and I should emphasize that if you had
an actual black hole that is produced in
through astrophysical processes you
don't get this full solution you only
get a portion of this solution because
usual black holes are not the solution
of the vacuum Einstein equations but the
solutions with matter and those black
holes those black holes would have a
geometry similar to the one we discuss
up to a certain parts and then you
encounter the matter of the star that
produced the black hole in space our
ends there and it doesn't have a second
side
um
but it's a very closely related geometry
okay so that that's one geometry that's
one part of the story another part of
the story comes from a different line of
reasoning which is uh thinking about
Hawking radiation so black holes have
this funny feature of emitting some
radiation so even though they are
solutions in the vacuum they look like
thermal objects they emit radiations as
if there were objects at some
temperature
and
this radiation is very small for
astrophysical black holes but could be
larger for smaller size black holes so
it's larger the temperature of the
radiation is after the smaller the black
hole is
you can you can even run into the
paradoxical situation of having a white
black hole because
if the black hole has the size of the
order of the microns but smaller the
macron the the size of the wavelength of
light
uh you you would see it white so
um
and
so that's a feature of black holes it
was gone to Mechanical aspects and by
thinking about this quantum mechanical
aspects and some other features of black
holes people came up with this
conjecture that I would I like to
sometimes call it the central dogma of
quantum black holes it's like you know
like there is a central dogma biology
that is central dogma of quantum aspects
of black holes which is that if you look
at the black hole from outside you can
think of it as an ordinary Quantum
system as an ordinary system it obeys
the loss of thermodynamics loss of
quantum mechanics and so on
um and it does so in a rather
non-trivial way we need an intricate the
way in which the
loss of physics conspired to give a
picture where this will be consistent
and
if you apply if you have this solution
like the one we discussed with Charles
that contains uh there is a closely
related solution where these two space
times that look completely disconnected
are actually part of the same space
actually you have a solution which looks
like two black holes that are separated
in space but are connected through
um
are connected through the interior so
they share a single interior
and um
the idea is that if you apply this sort
of central dogma separately to which
black holes which black hole can be
replaced by Quantum system
and then the peculiarity that produces
the connection is
or the idea is that the connection would
arise if these two Quantum systems are
entangled with each other so they have
epr or Einstein velocity Ross and
entanglement um
and um yeah so that's a
that's an idea for what it's an
interpretation if you wish of the
Russian solution in light of uh of this
this results of Hawking and others about
the Quantum Mass effects black holes
and again there the the fact that it is
not traversable is good because you
cannot send information using
entanglement so it's a consistency I
mean it's consistent with this
interpretation
um
now and people well we started this
relationship a lot to try to learn about
black hole Interiors basically that's
how we should think about black hole
interiors and there are weird features
about black hole Interiors such as this
one the two two separate black holes can
share the same interior for example
and uh so it's like an exotic system
that we would like to style it to
understand better in black on Interiors
um
now
okay now the the next development in
this direction uh came from an
observation paper by GAO Jeffries and
wall
um
and they
realize that if you introduce some
interaction between these two black
holes in the ambient space
you could get a signal to go through
this Wormhole and send the signal is
closely related to quantum teleportation
so if you have two Quantum systems that
are entangled
um then by doing certain measurements
and sending qubits on one of them and
sending classical information to the
other you could you could send the qubit
you could teleport the qubit and in in
this gravity picture the
the qubit is really Going Through the
Wormhole so you create
you do a certain operation using the
information so roughly speaking what you
do is you measure the Hawking radiation
on one black hole
and yeah sorry I should start from the
beginning you have the two entangled
black holes you send the qubit that you
want to send into one of the black holes
then you do you measure the hook in
radiation of that black hole you send
the information to the other
and by knowing that information the the
person in the other black hole can send
the negative ownership files is
something that normally could not be
done into a normal black hole but if you
roughly speaking the Hawking radiation
is random but if it is entangled with
another one and you measure the other
one you know what is going to happen
it's like having inside information is
like in the stock market market it looks
like a black hole if you don't know
nothing but if you have a friend inside
the company and tells you something that
I would never do that I would never
we'll cover economic trickery when we
get to uh the Higgs mechanism but yeah
but this is
um this is similar in the sense that you
can you can lower the energy go you send
in some negative ownership pulse and
then you can get out of the from the
interior this qubit that you sent on the
other side so it's a an interesting
picture for what's happening with
quantum teleportation and listening this
setup
and yeah so the these papers that you
mentioned were sort of developed in this
idea a little more uh just looking for
situations where very naturally you
would have this interaction between
these two black holes that it would
happen in uh for ordinary
four-dimensional black holes and so on
and uh so the
The crucial aspect in both well in all
the solutions is to have two black holes
that are relatively close to each other
so that there is some interaction
between them and so that this and this
particular entangle State those two
black holes is the ground state
configuration of the two Black Codes
that's a the quantum mechanical
interpretation if you wish
um or in terms of gravity that you can
form uh you can connect but you have
this connected Wormhole
um but um
but you create some negative energy
through some fields that propagate in
the space time so space time becomes
topologically non-trivial what it means
is that it develops some kind of handle
so you have the two black holes that are
like little holes in space and you
should picture them as connected by a
kind of host that connects the two black
holes so you can have particles that go
inside the hose and then come out in the
space and then go in again and
um
the propagation of these particles
creates some negative energy so in
quantum mechanics you can have negative
energy and that stabilizes the whole
setup and makes it possible to have a
Traverse over wormhub now
these stars are worthless you you build
this way
um are consistent with causality so what
does that mean that means that if you go
through the Wormhole you come out on the
other side later than you would have
come out if you had stayed outside the
Wormhole so they cannot be used for
traveling faster than light so
in the science fiction literature is
common to find the wormholes where that
are used to travel faster than light or
travel to the to the Past for example
and so on
um but this this we think are deeply uh
inconsistent with the loss of physics so
but this
so there are different things you can
mean by loss of physics so there are
general principles of physics that were
established in the beginning of the 20th
century like general relativity quantum
mechanics Quantum field Theory so these
are this is a kind of framework very
framework General framework with certain
solid principles so particular theories
that we have today obey these principles
but they kept changing because we needed
to add more particles we needed to add a
lot of particles since the beginning of
the 20th century all the quarks all the
um we now probably need to add the Dark
Matter particle and so on
um
but we whenever that was done it was
done within this framework
so we can ask what is possible within
this framework so what is possible with
ordinary this is what I'm going to call
ordinary matter
or non-exotic matter so it doesn't
doesn't mean the actual matter we have
in nature but this matter database these
kinds of principles that we could in
principle have perhaps but we haven't
detected yet for example
um and this uh the idea is that with
this kind of matter you cannot produce
uh wormholes that allow you to travel
faster than light
um and that's that's very good it's
actually an interesting theorem in uh
well
that that this is not possible it wasn't
completely proven but several aspects of
it were proven and it's an interesting
interplay between uh positivity
conditions of energy in relativistic
Quantum field Theory
um and general relativity
I mean at the level of geometry you can
imagine a geometry that connects points
that are far away I mean nobody forbids
you from writing down that geometry but
Einstein's theory is more than just the
arbitrary geometries it's a it's
geometries that obey a certain equation
it's called the Einstein equations
and the equation relates the shape of
the geometry to the amount of energy
yeah the amount of energy present in
this geometry energy or matter or
matter density Etc
and these shapes that would allow you to
travel faster than light they require a
certain kind of negative energy which is
possible
under those circumstances
a certain small amount of negative
energy is allowed by quantum mechanics
and it's what we exploited in the
solutions that we have discussed
and so so they allow you to construct
this these wormholes it's interesting
that you could have these configurations
which are have topology different than
the topology four-dimensional flat space
um
they seem difficult to build so we only
show that there are solutions we don't
know how
you could develop them into Solutions
and one interesting aspect is that the
the the first solution the first paper
you mentioned discusses these Solutions
in the context of it could even be the
standard model so it uh it could be the
the matter that we know but at very
short distances so distances that are so
black holes are very very tiny I mean
those black holes would be extremely
difficult to produce by artificial or
maybe natural means unless they were
producing the variable Universe
um and that's um
one possibility so
and those differ from the uh the 2020
paper differs in that it's
um it's actually displaying a five or
higher dimensional uh background
universe as opposed to the 2018 paper
which was four-dimensional Universe can
you comment on on why you it seems it
seems like we know we live in four
dimensions so why would we consider
higher Dimensions why can't we make it
work in four-dimens a humanly
traversable Wormhole and Fordham right
so the the construction we had in the 18
paper relied on the existence of light
matter
some light matter field so mother feeds
which are let's say almost massless and
we don't have such well we have the
photon in nature but we also wanted some
charged matter fields and we don't have
those
that we don't have massless ones we have
the electron that's massive
and um
so the idea was to postulate that maybe
we have some kind of Dark Sector so a
dark select sector would be some
type of matter that we only interact
with gravitationally but not directly so
in principle it might be possible
um and postulating such that Dark Sector
we were asking whether it would be
possible to
Wormhole that is big enough that a
person could travel
it was mostly as a fun project so let's
just do see what's possible um
and um there is these models that
involve extra extra dimensions are kind
of equivalent to a certain type of
four-dimensional matter theory of
four-dimensionality very mother Theory
massless matter
um
and when it's very strong interacting it
could be realized in terms of an extra
dimension
and these models were discussed in the
past so people thought oh maybe there
are extra Dimensions
um
and
so you could have the extra Dimensions
were flat like flat space they could
have a size which is somewhat smaller
than a millimeter
well now I think there is 50 microns is
the the current limit so it's rarely
smaller but
anyway so that's the current limit on
the size of extra Dimensions if they
were flat but Randall and sundrome
realized so to to researchers they they
realized that um
you could have this extra Dimension
could be actually have infinite infinite
size as long as the space was curved
um
and uh so so you have the extra
dimensional space is curved it has
negative curvature and then the extra
Dimension is large and uh it's the
physics of this problem is essentially
equivalent to adding massless matter to
four-dimensional to four dimensions so
if you don't like to think in terms of
four five Dimensions you can think in
terms of four dimensions
and
in this setup
um you could
by making the size of that extra
dimensional largely now so for the
experimental limit current experimental
limit of 50 microns you could have in
principle Traverse or wormhole
which is large enough for a person to go
through it so let me just very quickly
discuss how big it should be for us to
go through yeah
um now it's often said that the when we
fall into a black hole we die at the
singularity because the
tidal forces or the forces of gravity
will kill us
but
we could be falling into a black I mean
if we fall into a stellar Mass black
hole for example so a black hole with
the mass of the sun which has size of
order a few kilometers so if we fall
into such a black hole we are still
bigger than the size of the black hole
but it would be killed we would be
killed before we get even to the Horizon
because we are very frail people we we
are very sensitive to Tidal forces and
if we are pushed from The Head and the
toes in different directions we might
die
so actually
um you you need you need some black hole
a folder
um the size of the Earth so the Horizon
should be your order the size of the
Earth in order in order for us to fall
and not die at least at the horizon
and for similar reasons in this these
wormholes have to have a neck or an
opening so I mentioned the house before
connecting the two points in space-time
which has a size which is bigger than
the size of of the order of the size of
the Earth
and there are those circumstances you
could fall in and not be killed by the
tidal forces um
the tidal force is the force is similar
to the forces of Tides that create the
tides
in the surface of the Earth yeah on the
Earth
um anyway so that so that requires
pretty big uh black hole so that's a
little unfortunate that we are so
afrailed
um and uh this uh mechanism that reduces
the warmth house is also uh very
well
it requires some quantum mechanical
effects so it's not too efficient so you
can make more Imports but they accept
they will be separated the travel time
will be very long so will be
further 10 10 000. years so that's the
time it will take you to Go Through the
Wormhole I think by someone who remains
outside the warm hook
now something quite fun about this is
that if you for from the point of view
of the person that goes Through the
Wormhole that time is much shorter that
time is about uh it's less than a second
um
so
um it's a bit like the twins Paradox so
in the twins
Paradox there is um at one of the twins
remains at rest and the other one
travels at very high speeds and then
returns then the person who travels at
high speed and returns is much younger
than person who stayed at rest so this
is some something similar happens here
the person who goes Through the Wormhole
is much younger than the person who sits
outside the barn Hall
foreign and what do you attribute the
kind of Fascination that people have if
the time travel aspects as you guys show
are really not possible in the classic
sense and the interstellar uh movie
sense so to speak
um what why do you think people are so
fascinated and why do you think that
people use this as a as a plot device so
frequently uh that it's almost become
kind of a a Trope in a sense that people
really look look to wormholes to solve a
lot of problems and and movie plot
devices yeah well we I mean the speed of
light is
tough I mean it doesn't allow us to go
too far so it's not only a good idea
it's the law right yeah it's the law and
and it's uh
well it
I think authors like to go outside the
realm of ordinarily established laws of
physics they
usually the the statement is oh well now
we that's what we think now maybe in the
future we'll realize there is a way to
go around it and that might well be true
so it might well be true that we find a
way to around but going around this it's
a very serious change to the loss of
physics so I I personally would bet very
strongly against actually I remember the
the
a few years ago there was an experiment
claiming that the neutrinos traveled
faster yeah the Opera experiment that's
right
yeah so I met one of my neighbors and so
you see you know relativity is wrong and
so on
so okay fine I bet you thousand dollars
that this experiment will go away
he didn't want to take the bed
financially wise uh
uh and yeah I mean it is possible
everything is possible but there are
some things that are more unlikely than
others yeah a lot of times we talk on
this channel and we have talked about
you know theories of everything which I
definitely want to get into uh with you
as well I can't miss the opportunity to
discuss it but you know oftentimes this
kind of uh perception that such things
are not really falsifiable or not
testable and so why should we kind of
expend time energy money which is so
finite in in value in in amount but
infinite in value whatever kind of some
of the motivations to study these things
when you know for example some of the
criticism you know on the internet of
the of the recent humanly traversable
Wormhole theory is that you know we
don't even know if the Randall sundrome
cosmology model five or whatever even
exists and there's no evidence for that
so why study you know kind of an edifice
that's built upon something which may
not even exist
right right right so here here we we are
exploring not the the things that nature
exists but possible Natures that are
consistent with the loss of the general
principles of physics or general
relativity and special relativity and
set quantum mechanics
um with the goal of just understanding
what is possible the goal is not so it's
not so much to go and build and look for
this Wormhole it's just well
that paper was just a fine exercise but
the main main goal is to I think the
main goal is to understand black holes
better Quantum aspects of black holes
with the goal of understanding why about
how quantum gravity works so black holes
are an interesting problem because they
force us to think about counting graph
in interesting ways and and if um does
that not presuppose that there exists a
a theory of everything in other words is
it mandatory certainly it seems that
um wormholes at least non-uh Simply
Connected regions are permissible In
classical gr but certainly to have the
Wormhole as described uh in the paper
seems to rely on on Quantum processes as
you as you very rightfully explained but
um but I want to ask maybe a deeper
question which is kind of your opinion
on theories of everything in general
which is that you know do we need a
Theory of Everything Is it mandatory
that we have yeah I I don't like to
match the world theory of everything
and I didn't use it no but I I think
what we need is the theory of one with
the with called quantum gravity so
quantum mechanics of space-time or a
theory of quantum space-time and this is
needed because the current theorists do
not explain what happens in certain
circumstances like what happens at the
very beginning of the Big Bang or what
happens in the interior of black holes
and um we would need that theory to
really put all these principles that we
discussed at the beginning of 20th
century together and
if you call that everything yeah that's
uh yeah of everything that we learned in
the 20th century general relativity and
quantum physics
um
the formalism of quantum field Theory
came from putting together quantum
mechanics and special relativity
and I think we like to put in general
relativity and and
this is a very very constrained
structure so the question I mean one
question that
I think that the fact that we need this
theory is clear uh you could question
whether we will ever get this Theory
without doing experiments
so I think this is a valid question now
why why do we think we might get there
like this is that
well we have some examples of candidate
theories that are mostly like we should
really think of them as theories under
construction like string theory and so
on which uh
which have lots of mathematical
intricacies and error put together
managed to put together gravity and
quantum mechanics
we don't know whether it's the Right
theory for nature we don't know if
that's the correct framework to correct
Theory special Theory to describe nature
but their goal I think is to is that by
thinking about those theories you might
even be able to abstract some principles
could be used to describe nature
and um in the process people discuss
discover all kinds of relationships
between this series and Mathematics and
other areas of physics and might uh even
uh
and and we now think that gravity and
quantum mechanics are connected in many
different ways and
so perhaps a provocative idea is that
you might be able to build a little toy
universe in a lab so yeah yeah see your
morale A friend of mine has written a
book about a big bang in a little room
which is a wonderful little book
um I wanna uh before I turn to questions
from the audience I do just want to
follow up and just I can't resist and if
you'll indulge me you know I mean it's
not so often I have a great physicist to
chat with uh live and ask questions of a
not personal nature but I'd love to get
your opinion on why are there so many
different theories of everything I mean
there's Wolfram has one our mutual
friend Eric Weinstein has had one uh
Garrett Lisi I mean they seem to
proliferate and these are very very you
know legitimate uh ideas some of which
are are very creative Stephen Wolfram
has a completely different approach from
the geometric uh approaches of people
like Lisi and Weinstein uh why don't you
attribute first of all the the
upsurgents in interest in new and
theories of everything
um
um well I guess
it's a natural Frontier and people have
different ideas for how things should go
some some ideas are more developed than
others uh
and have had a I mean yeah like of
course the final Arbiter of any idea is
uh to make a definite experimental
prediction that you know could be
falsified or basically a prediction that
you could go and check
that this theory has and there have been
no predictions like this for from any of
the theories
um but along the way some some theories
have had more uh predict or let's say
mathematical predictions or predictions
for other use of physics or
some interesting more interesting
structure
and some are consistent with these
principles of the 20th century physics
that they discussed and some are not so
for example it's not clear whether
Walgreens ideas are consistent with the
principles of Relativity and causality
and so on time doesn't it's not
and uh
yeah so
um
yeah I think the for those of us that
work on string inspired ideas the what
we like is that it's a theory with
well-defined roles and well at least in
some regimes where you can do
calculations and it's compatible with
this general principles
uh dentition Century physics and when we
look at some of the questions are coming
up about connections between Quantum
field Theory one of my listeners whose
name is Rust in Peace who is a frequent
contributor on the channel he's asking
uh whether or not the black hole
information Paradox shows that Quantum
field theory is incomplete in other
words do we need a fundamentally new
Theory uh to merge quantum mechanics and
gr as illustrated by the black hole
paradox
yes I think I think I think that's right
but it's incomplete when when gravity is
dynamical so when the effects of
when the effects of the finiteness of
the Newton constant is is important so
and then others are asking about you
know the perceived I get this a lot you
know failure of string theory to you
know come up with this but I think I
think you've already sort of addressed
this that it may be sort of too much to
ask for or maybe not phrasing the
meaning of the word theory of everything
and and maybe there's too much
expectation of things like string theory
so what's your current appraisal of the
of the State of Affairs and string
theory for example
um well I think uh String Theory I view
it mainly as a candidate theory for
quantum gravity and uh it's a theory
that's been fairly developed and has a
very interesting mathematical structure
and has led to
um
interesting connections between Quantum
field Theory and gravity or between
different Quantum field areas and
Quantum filtering condensed matter and
quantum mechanics and
thinking about yeah quantum mechanics
and space-time in general and
if
but yeah the fact that there isn't a
concrete experimental prediction is a
problem and uh I think
we we understood that the landscape of
possible there was a roadmap for example
experimental predictions in the late 80s
which was well we'll we'll have we have
this very nice 10-dimensional Theory and
we'll find the internal space on which
it's compactified so six dimensions are
small we'll find the possible shapes
there will be a finite small number of
possible shapes will uh we'll find which
is the one that gives the standard model
and we'll be able to calculate things
that that was the roadmap
um that roadmap turned out to be uh well
it was more complicated than expected
because there were many many possible
shapes and many the number was so big
that it's very difficult to study them
them all or study them in a way that you
could really make a concrete prediction
and the current thinking is that the
the adjusting it into to explain or
accommodate the cosmological constant
you need to to uh to exploit this
complexity and
and so
so the typical like the typical so if
you take an off-the-shelf internal space
you will get the cosmetrical content
which is too large
so the idea that the current idea well
among all the one there are so many that
one will have the right cosmological
constant but that also makes it they're
very difficult to make a concrete
prediction
but I mean people are some people are
are still
um well they're definitely many people
are trying to make statistical
predictions so maybe you don't know
exactly which of the vacuum where we
live in or which but making perhaps
statistical predictions of what that
landscape sometimes called the string
landscape of what that landscape looks
like
I personally think that also this
connection between gravity and and
quantum mechanics maybe can lead to a
different kind of prediction a different
kind of uh connection between the idea
these ideas and and the rest of physics
and concrete physics which is via
perhaps quantum computers and maybe
Quantum experiments in the lab of
building something some systems some
complex ideas that very complex systems
behave in a way that can be described by
a certain space-time and it's not our
four-dimensional space-time but maybe
some auxiliary two-dimensional
space-time and so on and there are
people thinking more actively about the
how to get these ideas to to work
and so this is again something that
people you know doing String Theory do
but it's a different angle upon
connection
and kind of an Allied effect to that is
uh located behind my upper right
shoulder over here I'm pointing to a
couple of CMB balls I want to uh bring
up an Allied question which is related
to the Multiverse and you mentioned the
landscape I want to talk a little bit
about that
um in our remaining 15-20 minutes that
we have so I want to read something to
you from a while back in Quantum
magazine which uh which talked about the
study of non-gaussianides and in Quantum
magazine they say the study of rigorous
study of non-gaussianides took off in
2002 when wal maldisena revered
monk-like theorists at The Institute for
advanced study calculated what's known
as a gravitational floor the minimum
number of triangles and other shapes
that are guaranteed to exist in the sky
due to the unavoidable effect of gravity
during Cosmic inflation cosmologists had
been struggling to calculate the
gravitational floor for more than a
decade since it would provide a concrete
goal for experimentalists if the floor
is reached and still no triangles are
detected maltesena explained then
inflation is wrong so I want to ask you
because I don't I actually interviewed a
real monk last week and I have to say
you guys have some somewhat similar you
know countenances you're very very
revered and very reserved but I don't
know if the monk-like attribute is is
accurate but but leaving that aside
behind me are these balls I'm gonna go
get one while you're on the screen but
can you first talk a little bit about
what is a non-gaussianity in the
cosmological context and I'll bring up
some visuals for the audience while uh
you indulge me
yeah so the
an interesting fact about the universe
is that it's very close to uniform on
long distances
but and I think in fact it's not
perfectly uniform there were some
primordial inhomogeneity so it was the
first approximation homogeneous but with
tiny little in homogeneities that I
guess you've been studying for you know
your career and that's a map of the
dosing homogeneous as we see them
through the CMB
um this in homogeneity is believed that
they were produced through Quantum
effects they were due to Quantum
fluctuations during the beginning of
inflation
um and so they are random so the Phantom
fluctuations are random
but in quantum theory the
um
the randomness has some pattern so
um so there are different patterns of
randomness
and so a simplest pattern is so called
gaussian pattern where each each region
could sort of fluctuate independently of
the others roughly speaking it's not
exactly this but
um each let's say way fluctuates
differently from the others and that's
like the simplest pattern the bell curve
the gaussian distribution
um but
in in actual theories uh actual theories
are interacting and the fluctuation in
one place creates some decreases or
increases another type of fluctuation in
a similar region so
um so you have some known gaussian
effects so some donation means that
there were some interactions between the
waves you could view these as waves or
fluctuations in the geometry of the
shape of the universe
and
we
this uh these deviations from gaussian I
think gives us very deep information
about the interactions that were present
during the inflationary times during the
times of inflation when these
fluctuations were produced
um and so the simplest interaction that
we had was the interaction of gravity so
that if you have a fluctuation that
create it's created an over density okay
it created some gravitational potential
and then some other fluctuation would
would look different
and that's this so-called gravitational
floor so it's the minimum amount of non
deviations from the gaussianity that you
would need if inflation is correct at
least or at least single field inflation
but in principle there could be larger
effects due to other particles that
could could have existed during that
time
and in some some ways the early
inflation is like a particle detector or
a particle collider that you
you you create all these particles
that could be created so the universe at
the time was expanding rapidly and
there's an effect similar to the effect
of hoping radiation that we discussed
before that creates this Quantum effect
that creates this this waves this
fluctuations
and you can also create other particles
which have mass to the effective
temperature of these equations
and
they
um so if you created those particles it
could also imprint all kinds of
interesting patterns in the sky I mean
so far so far no non-gaussianides were
detected so
that is uh so it's very very close to
gaussian but still there are a couple of
orders of magnitude to go to
to get to this floor somehow to this
minimal amount and I guess there are
very interesting experiments going on
trying to
calculate this to measure I mean to
experimentally measure this non-gaussian
it is better yeah that's right and it's
certainly a Hot Topic not only the uh
the actual pursuit of non-gaussianides
which is there are very few ways we can
actually access this enormous particle
accelerator as you call it which is a
nice way to think about the extremely
early universe but one of them is
potentially through Cosmic microwave
backgrounds polarization and in doing so
we make the hypothesis that if inflation
took place there will be this stochastic
background of primordial gravitational
waves not the late time gravitational
waves detected recently fairly recently
on Cosmic time scales by Lee by ligo but
actually we could detect a a background
suffusing the early Universe
unfortunately these are kind of like
no-go theorems in some sense and what
appeals to me and I should take a step
back what I liked about the
non-gaussianity effect is that it gives
another it gives a prediction that's a
lower limit so I'm kind of sick of upper
limits we've had so many upper limits in
physics for so long that it's nice
sometimes to get a lower limit so let me
explain to my audience who might not be
familiar an upper limit says that a
signal can be no larger than a certain
amount so it says that the Higgs boson
could be no larger than you know three
you know 300 or or whatever gev in Mass
but a lower limit allows you to say that
such a quantity exists and it's bigger
than a certain value and in fact that
value can be bigger than zero so for
example we know that neutrinos have mass
we have an upper limit on the mass of
neutrinos from neutrino oscillation
experiments we also uh know that there's
a lower limit on the on the mass of the
neutrino sorry we know the lower limit
exists from from neutrino oscillations
we know the upper limit exists from from
collider experiments from direct
detection experiments and from cosmology
and so we're kind of coming at the
target from both ends it's not enough to
say I'm lower than you know 600 meters
tall and I'm bigger than one micron tall
what you'd like to have is a very tight
range between the upper and lower limits
but when you have a lower limit it gives
a target for an experimentalist like me
I always say I'm just a simple
experimental astrophysicist you got to
break it down into and there are very
few things like that we know that we
don't know that gravitational waves
exist and the primordial sense we know
that they exist in the late universe but
uh but your your work on
non-gaussianidas really provides sort of
a no-go theorem which could be used in
in combination with the primordial B
mode search but there's a problem in
that I think that we've we've basically
hit a point of diminishing returns when
you wrote that paper in the early 2000s
that was pre-w-map and now we have not
only the beautiful phenomenal world you
know changing results of wmap but also
Plank and it's very hard to do much
better in the cmb's temperature so I
wonder you know how much better can we
do to you know in the in your opinion
before we hit this floor which is known
as Cosmic variants uh it Beyond which we
can't really improve in other words
might your lower limit uh also be an
upper limit in the sense that we'll
never be able to detect it because of
fundamental intrinsic variances in the
in the pattern of fluctuations in the
microwave background
um well that's I think a subject you
probably know better than me
um and uh I'm I'm told by the experts
that with the the current angular
resolution that you could get the CMB
with and so on uh you just don't have
enough uh Power to get to this floor
yeah I think we're getting very close I
mean yeah diminishing returns in terms
of noise level and angular resolution uh
but there may be other triangles in in
terms of large-scale structure is that a
possibility to look for non-gaussianides
yeah so large scale structure is
something that would allow you to go a
little further because you see
basically one difference is that the the
CMB map is two-dimensional and our skill
structure could be a three-dimensional
map
and there's been also some more
futuristic ideas like you know looking
at the so-called 21 centimeter headers
animation lines to to see the matter
distribution also in the early universe
and to again make a map which is
three-dimensional
and uh I mean that that might be the
best hope but well people yeah
this is further into the future we don't
know that 21 centimeters primordial
signal is really there
ask you a question that's maybe a meta
question when you make a prediction
about this how difficult is it to
separate your own Natural Curiosity and
feeling of ownership over this Theory I
mean I think we could both agree it'll
be very challenging to detect a humanly
traversable Wormhole but when you make
predictions such as these no-go theorems
for inflation or the many other
contributions you've made to physics how
much how tempting is it as a theorist to
really Advocate you know for the pursuit
of your particular theoretical models
and and and see confirmation in them
wherever they are yeah yeah I think I
think there are theories that the
proposed models uh like they're more
more phenomenologies that produce models
I wouldn't call this humanly traversable
model as a particular theory that I want
to see confirmed in experiment because I
think it's very unlikely that the the
universe is described by the Randall
syndrome 2 model and so on
um maybe you must a little more
theoretical fun exercise a bit of
Science Fiction
I told Lisa Randall that I was going to
write a science fiction paper I think he
should
be another side of the monk no
[Laughter]
yeah I I I tend to work on things
which are
not predicting specific models but
trying to find general principles and
yeah General ideas exploring
this more General features
but uh
yeah I
for example with with Nema we discussed
the
the possibility of seeing extra
particles during inflation and so on
through this cosmology calculator would
be really fun if that was seen I mean
there would be
quite well
again I I don't think it's necessarily
likely we didn't we didn't think that it
was the most likely scenario right so
I think part of the theorist
work is to figure out where interesting
signals could lie
or where you should look for interesting
signals
there might not be necessarily
the most likely signals but if they were
present they would tell you a lot so you
should make sure there are certain
signals you should make sure not to
admit at least
um
and uh yeah that's uh
part of what I'm doing but some some
people are more more practically
oriented and want to see what is
actually the data is saying and the
the yeah what can be extracted from
actual data that you for example are
taking right and to what extent you know
if you were kind of a director of
experimental research how would you
choose to prioritize just on a selfish
level your many enthusiasms that you
have
um how would you you know rate the
likelihood of the existence of these
Randall syndrome I mean you obviously
say that there's not not terribly likely
and they're almost in the realm of
Science Fiction as are wormholes but
inflation is held in the Multiverse the
string landscape swampland these are all
held by you know there's an awful lot of
energy devoted at most universities to
this Pursuit so how do you how would you
or if you were the director of all
research in physics on planet Earth from
your Monastery how would you how would
you allocate this very precious limited
amount of time or really attention
mm-hmm
um well you have to decide where well
I think this run this this Randall
sundrome well the particular version
that we considered I think it's highly
unlikely
um
in general the randerson my idea is an
interesting idea uh no not this
particular model but the one that was
trying to explain the hierarchy model
and should be explained should be
explored
has the nice feature that the simple
relatively simple to explore relative to
other particle physics scenarios
and it's a it's slightly different
scenario than the ones typically people
consider like new particles structure
which is basically similar to the one we
already had
um and so it's worth looking for it
produces weird signals so it's
interesting
to look at and people looked at it in
mainly in the run-up to the LHC as
possible things that the LHC could see
now the LHC didn't see any of them but
it was important that it looked for all
this all the possible things so it was
an era before the experiment where
I think it was important to look for
exotic scenarios look for
you know possibilities like super
symmetry look for various possibilities
and well then use the experiment and you
make sure you don't miss any any
possible signal
so
I think something that is important is
some diversity in in approaches in
various ideas so I think if you ask me
what sign policy should be you should
find different uh
various ideas
just in theory but various different
ideas you said just in theory or do you
mean in theory this is a very important
principle in experiment it's a little
more tricky because sometimes you need a
critical mass of people following
uh definite you know definite experiment
and
you know there are many many people
studying Cosmic microwave physics and I
think it's a very interesting
very interesting topic and I feel yeah
so now one of the Frontiers is the study
of the primordial fluctuations I find
this the most interesting aspects of
CNBC I mean CMB physics has many more
aspects very well measuring neutrino
masses that you mentioned and then I
don't know the physics of early clusters
Etc and but yeah this this
this discovery of primordial
fluctuations is very interesting for
what it says about the universe the
consequences it has for us I mean we are
here thanks to these primordial
fluctuations in a way and
um
so I think it's a conceptually very
interesting area I mean very interesting
results that
people should know and and
find for the public to know uh
again you could say well this doesn't
give any technological application and
so on but I think it's a fundamental
scientific thing that is interesting for
for us to know
it has a very important and cultural
value
and speaking of cultural value there's
other ideas and you know there's an
approach to let a thousand theories
Bloom so to speak so I'm getting
questions about your impressions of
alternates to inflation obviously you've
spent a lot of time thinking about
inflation but um what if inflation
didn't happen what if the models of your
nearby neighbor over across the way and
Jadwin Hall Paul steinhardt is a friend
of the show this sort of cyclic bouncing
models or Roger Penrose who's been also
been on the show discussing conformal
cyclic cosmology what are your thoughts
uh on those on those models alternatives
to an inflationary story
um well I I should say that I think it's
it's interesting to try to find
alternatives to try to follow
alternatives to inflation
um and uh we were discussing with some
students some some Alternatives and but
I have to say that none of the
Alternatives reach the level of
precision and rigor just even
theoretical rigor uh that inflation has
so inflation is an idea where you take
the simplest idea uh stereowinsky model
and you can do the calculation of
fluctuations in that model was done
and um and you get some prediction and
you know the prediction doesn't change
so it's not that a new theories come and
they change the prediction and it
depends on exactly how you do the
calculation another there is a
well-defined way to do the calculation
and that's it
in these other models it's unclear what
the roots are for doing the calculation
so the models have
um an uncalculable element so some
levels of assumption in in the model
itself so you say well you start with
some well-defined process there is a
point where
an unknown physics happens where you
need a quantum theory of gravity so some
Theory we don't completely have and then
you make some assumption and then you
get some prediction
but the prediction changes with the
Assumption and maybe the Assumption
changed and well I mean it
it doesn't mean that those models are
all wrong I mean maybe there could be an
idea the conceptual idea might be
correct but they certainly not calculate
doesn't have the level of calculation at
all even already internally the
calculation of the rigor that inflation
has so as a theory uh they're behind in
that sense
um
yeah comparing to experiment well many
of these models were designed to agree
with experiments
uh at least the experiment so far but
yeah they some of them make different
predictions so
right yeah I guess the question is
attention you know there's such a
dominance in most departments have you
know uh cosmologists where they're
working on inflation if they have you
know early Universe cosmology uh we have
multiple people here at San Diego we're
very fortunate my colleagues Rafael
flaugher Dan Green and others um but but
thinking about Alternatives and how
difficult it is to get traction imagine
you do come up with some Theory and you
are working more or less I mean my the
way I always put it is people like Eric
Weinstein or people like Roger Penrose
cannot get traction you know and not
have graduate students and sort of
people working on it how how easy is it
or or how how does the kind of Monopoly
effect does it does it take place where
a theory is so dominant it's so
attractive that it basically sucks out
the oxygen from Alternatives that may
prove Superior had they had the
intellectual Capital behind them
um
well I mean
it is a problem if everyone does the
same thing but I think there is an
incentive for people to come up with
another theory that is a competitor
um
um but that this it has to be a serious
competitor in the sense that uh at least
it has to be internally internally
somewhat lesson calculable or
and there are and there are people
working on some Alternatives it's not I
mean there was a paper today about some
other alternative Theory so
um
I
I think it's well I think people there
are people proposing alternative
scenarios but if the alternative
scenario is very vague it doesn't get
traction because you yeah you don't know
what what's the next step or what
I mean it's good to have in mind and my
feeling is that perhaps uh someone
working in some problems in you know
quantum gravity or gravity in general
might have an idea for a slightly for a
different scenario
perhaps and then that would be
reasonable and would lead to either
different yeah but at least it has to
agree with the predictions have been
checked but uh experimentally I mean uh
the scaling bar the the nearly scale
environment spectrum of fluctuations and
so on
um but
um yeah it could lead to other
predictions I think it's interesting to
come up with different theories I mean
historically for example
people France and DK came up with this
alternative theory of gravity where
there is also scalar force and so on and
that played the
I mean that had the advantage of being a
theoretically well-defined Theory and
then you could use it to compare you
know experiments against the
you take gr and this other Theory
general relativity and this other Theory
and you could compare them and and see
what what you get so
yeah I wanted to then turn towards a
completely different direction which is
your paper
entitled the Symmetry and simplicity of
the laws of physics and the Higgs boson
were used theories of Economics as an as
an analog to help people understand an
approach to how the how this very
complex notion the so-called Higgs
mechanism could be understood in terms
of a monetary or economic analogy and
that was building on as you site you
know the work of my friends Pia malali
and Eric Weinstein in the um sort of
what they consider and and they've
talked to me about this sort of an
upgrade of differential calculus and I
want to ask you are there other
applications of gauge through I mean if
you ask people they might have heard of
calculus not the kind on on my teeth or
something but they might have heard of
calculus they might know what a
derivative is or an integral but almost
none of them know what a gauge you know
theory is so first of all
um what is a gauge Theory why is it
useful to physicists and are there other
analogs that could be used to either
understand gauge Theory as you use
economics based on you know p and Eric's
work but also uh to extend this to other
fields where you know people like me
might not see the connection between
gauge Theory and some other analog and
physical world
um yeah so gauge theory is basically a
theory where you introduce some
redundancies
that help you
understand the
that help you describe the theory but
that they are not do not reflect the
physics or
they're not real so insert you produce
something which is kind of conventional
and
you and but at the end of the day it's
not the it doesn't reflect reality
an example is well the gauge potential
of electromagnetism so the both the the
electric potential or magnetic
potentials that we discussed for
electromagnetism they are not they're
not physical you can shift them by
constants you can shift them by some
certain particular functions and what's
really physical are the electric and
magnetic fields on
electromagnetism is a gauge theory in
this sense and many of the theories of
particle physics are also gauge Theory
so it's a very important type of theory
that we we use to describe physics
and
yeah so the this economic analogy is
based on uh thinking about
um it's an analogy between economics and
electromagnetism
and uh
it uh well should I describe it there
yeah so maybe no please tell yeah yeah
so the basic idea is to think about the
currency so people uh
sometimes well so for example dollars
right we measure things in dollars but
if someone decided to change the value
of the dollar say let's say people
tomorrow they decide that well a hundred
dollars of today will be valid one new
dollar tomorrow let's say we could
invented a different name let's say one
one peso let's say so yes and one we
call them one pesos change the number of
series and Define a new unit of currency
but if all the salaries are just
appropriately and all the exchange rates
with other currencies in the world not
just appropriately that change doesn't
affect anybody and doesn't uh
it's just the change in the units we
used to measure what the value of things
and I came from a country in Argentina
where this happened many times so many
times they took a few zeros out of the
currency
um through this type of process um
now that's an example of a gauge
symmetry that's a something that doesn't
change how rich you are because you
change the number of zeros you have in
the currency
um
now there's some other more physical
information in the uh more real
information in the exchange rates
between different countries so
but not exactly exchange rates between
two countries because if you have the
exchange rate only between two countries
if any one of them changes the currency
that the particular nominal value the
change rate will also change so when you
change the currency units
but if you have
um the exchange rates between three
different countries and imagine them
arranging the vertex of a triangle and
so you have the exchange rate between
any of the two countries along the edges
of the triangle
then each individual's
exchange rate depends on the on the
currency units of each one but imagine
you travel between the three countries
in a in a circle
the net gain that you get by exchanging
those exchange rates
that's uh independent of the currency
units so if you gain a factor of two or
a factor of 1.1 when you go around in
one way or you lose a factor you know
you get the fact of 0.09 I mean 0.09 um
that is really physical and that's what
in physics we call a magnetic field so
um it's analogous to magnetic field
now if you have a situation like this
where you can make money by going around
these three countries then you would
have speculators that buy one currency
sell it and so on and now normally this
wouldn't happen
if we were in equilibrium or but
um you would think that the exchange
rates would adjust themselves so that
this doesn't happen but imagine for a
second that the exchange rates are
arbitrary and you could make money by
doing this then you would have
speculators that go around this
these three countries
now this is what happens in nature when
you have a an electron so an electron
goes around the magnetic field so you
have a magnetic field the electron goes
around in a circle and so the electron
is a bit like those speculators that are
trying to make money
um
and um yeah so that's an example and
and yeah so you can have fun some fun
with this example and you can
assume some behavior for the people who
set the exchange rates and the
speculators and so on and get the
Maxwell equations Etc
um I mean this is not too surprising
given that Maxwell himself got the
Maxwell equations from a mechanical
model and we think we don't have that
particular mechanical model that Maxwell
had but there are many microscopic
models that give rise to Maxwell's
equations this is just one of them
um
now the the
but in actual economics the
um we're in sort of like a Higgs phase
of electromagnetis is analogous to a
situation where the electromagnetism
spontaneously broken and because the
prices of ordinary Goods that we can
take between one country and the next is
analogous to the Hicks the Higgs field
so like we could have a certain one
certain thing like gold or oil or you
know bananas that we can take between
different countries and so the
speculators go also Commerce in this uh
quantities and um
the prices of these quantities are
[Music]
well are certainly arbitrary they depend
on the monetary units but we could
um we could set our monetary units in
terms of those prices so we can some all
the countries could decide well we've
measure everything in terms of the price
of bananas anyway and that's uh
then the exchange rates between
different countries would become more
meaningful
and um
yeah so well that's that's roughly the
the analogy I could go on on it on this
and then are there other you know kind
of approaches that where gauge Theory
might not be uh widely appreciated as a
you know potential uh potential under
you know way to understand
to understand something well yeah I
don't I
I don't know so you are asking me to
find the other analogies
I don't know of another one that is as
close as uh economic month
um
yeah and then of course with the Higgs
you make or a lecture week for us you
talk about you know spheres replacing
circles I think that's delightful and uh
an interesting extension of the work
um that we discussed I want to talk uh
just in the final few minutes if you if
you still have a little bit more time
we'll finish up soon a couple more
questions from people uh in the in the
chat room how how is it possible that by
adding uh these Dimensions it seems a
little reminiscent of you know calooza
Klein
Etc so what what's the difference
between a physical Dimension which we
have no evidence of existing and sort of
a mathematical Dimension where we can
add things that will even though they
may not exist in in in reality
um
well a physical Dimension is some
Dimension where some Physics can happen
so
you know a particle can move in the
extra Dimensions gravity can extend to
the extra dimensions and so on so that's
what we normally call the physical
dimension
I'm not sure what the mathematical
Dimension is I mean of course the
concept of many dimensions in math makes
sense and it could be applied to depends
on what your mathematical application is
so
for example people who think about the
you know recognizing language artificial
intelligence or language think of words
as vectors in a higher dimensional space
and stuff like this so this is some
other application of the idea of the
dimension that has nothing to do right
and Gage just you know being analogous
vocabulary lookup table between
different cultures or languages yeah
um a few more questions uh from from
both me and my audience so one involves
uh you're at this very a little bit less
technical now if you'll indulge us so uh
you're at the one of the most storied
institutions uh and the annals of all of
science The Institute for advanced study
uh what is sort of your daily life like
there is it all you know contemplation
or what's a day in the life of of
besides your six hours of prayer fasting
every day as a monk what what's a day
look like for you uh Dr Mel designer
well I think my day is similar to the
days in of University researchers we
normally we go come to our offices we
look we look at the papers that came out
the previous night
we we discussed with our colleagues we
maybe are working on some papers we do
calculations
as a theorist we spend a lot of time
discussing calculations and math and
you know different approaches to
actually doing certain calculations
there is of course maybe some discussion
of more
conceptual things but that's what we
mostly spend our days on there we go to
talks presentations
like
and then uh in terms of
um you know kind of future things that
you're interested in uh what sort of the
near-term looking like for you in terms
of research directions maybe students
and advisories yeah so I currently we're
we're all work we're all mainly working
on my group working on the aspects of
black holes Quantum aspects of black
holes trying to understand
what the black hole interior is
understanding better than information
Paradox and
there was a
recently very interesting progress on
understanding how the information comes
out in Hawking radiation
papers by
Pennington and what by various research
groups and
and yeah so that's a very exciting
development in the last couple of years
and so I've been working mostly on that
um
so the last question that I have let me
just scan the chat section here we've
got a hundred plus people in the chat
section A lot of these have been have
been asked so I think we've covered most
of the questions from the audience I'm
going to finish up with two questions
for you that I ask in some version or
another I ask most if not all of my
guests and that first question kind of
relates to the the far future of of
humanity you know hopefully you live to
be you know many well first of all I
want to ask you actually I don't I don't
get this opportunity very often if I
could give you one of my kids is working
on a pill which he calls the Never Dying
pill which would allow the uh the the
ingester whoever eats it to live forever
but no one else on the entire planet
would live forever I want to ask you one
would you take such a pill to live
forever as you are right now with
everything you know can't take anyone
with you not even me
yeah I don't know maybe
yes yeah probably yes okay and the next
question revolves around something that
in Hebrew is known as an ethical will so
Alfred Nobel left the famous will which
endowed a prize that bears his name
but the will in addition to recognizing
uh discoveries and inventions and
physics chemistry Etc was meant also to
benefit all mankind so to have some
benefit towards the human species and so
in that way it was what was known as an
ethical will it had more than just a
monetary Financial tangible purpose and
and an outcome of it I want to ask you
if you were to write an ethical will
what kind of wisdom or or things
knowledge that you've obtained in your
life would you want to pass on separate
completely from your your financial
material will
well the importance of collaboration of
Truth seeking in general
um I think
these are
important principles
see yourself primarily as an educator as
a researcher as a mentor a student how
do you how do you think of yourself and
what what is your sort of superpowers
that allow you to be so successful
well I think of myself as a researcher
first and yeah also mentor
I have the Opera well one of the secrets
is that we have outstanding young people
coming through the Institute that become
our collaborators and so on and uh yeah
that's uh that's perhaps one of the
greatest privileges of being here
I want to ask you what would you put on
a monolith a time capsule that would
represent the culmination of of physics
knowledge or personal knowledge that
would last for a billion years as a time
capsule for the future
[Music]
yeah I think this this idea that
matter is made out of particles is very
important
probably
that perhaps general relativity depends
on how much you can put in but
right yeah the sentence could be a
run-on sentence made out of small
particles that's something that fits in
a sentence but
very good uh well uh Dr Juan maldassena
it's been a pleasure to talk to you I
hope to uh maybe contact you again in
the future as I develop a little more
understanding of your uh excellent
papers very provocative very
entertaining papers as as is your style
and I appreciate this very much I'll put
some resources in the show note links to
your papers links to a talk you gave at
The Institute uh several years back on
the same topic I want to express my
gratitude to you Juan for sharing uh so
much of your time with my audience today
sure it's a pleasure yeah thanks thank
you one be well I'll talk to you again
soon thank you very much bye-bye